[Music]
good evening everyone to the Grandmaster
Choice lecture and I choose to show you
the game from this year's US
Championship against Grandmaster Ray
Robson and this was a last round game I
wasn't fighting for the first place or
top places but I was more like fighting
not to finish at the end you know so I
needed to win this game with the black
pieces so I decided you know Ray was
half a point ahead of me and I needed to
play for a win and he surprised me he
always plays efore against me but this
came as a surprise he's done this before
actually but so far he didn't worked out
for him he both times he played
surprising it was b4 and c4 he lost both
games so his results are better with
ephors I expect next time he'll play
four against me so I played a 6 this is
the last round of the this year's US
Championship ok Knight c3 d5
d for
now we have Queens gambit declined
Knight f6 Knight f6 okay developing C
takes d5 e takes d5 and Bishop g5 and
can you please let me know what opening
we have currently we started with c4
like it looked like it's gonna be
English but we transpose into yes yeah
it's more like Queens gambit declined
okay
no one has qgd okay we transpose into
qgd okay yeah Queen's opening but the
exact name is cou Queen's Gambit the
client so I go see six-year guys with
some Bishop f5 ideas he goes Queen c2 he
is trying to prevent me from playing
Bishop f5 now I play Bishop e7 just
developing III
night bd7 Bishop d3 and now what to do
now what is the idea here that you're
gonna be able to hear yes
fantastic that's what I played actually
many years ago they would always Castle
and play this Rukia tonight a faith plum
but this Knightly trial is gaining some
popularity interesting setup and now he
has to take I take ok and now the idea
is just to play g6 and get the
development ok so now he goes here 9g to
and now
now I if I Castle he's gonna take on h7
right I don't want that to happen so
what are we going to do
yes
we could do that the only thing you
gotta be there be careful leaving that
night on the Remi now remember night on
the rim is lonely and dim right so you
gotta be a little bit careful on that
okay I do want to cancel though you need
to make a move to castle
so what useful move can you make to
castle here guys
useful good move yes
right you could do that I I my night is
gonna come back for sure but right now
it's actually doing an okay job
restricting you know there's two squares
you know go ahead what do we do
absolutely
excellent yes g6 I shut down the bishop
and I keep the night there for now okay
so he castles I Castle yeah I Castle he
Castle and now my opponent went here
okay one
now he's planning to play Knight c1 f3
Knight B 3 E 4 this is what he's trying
to do ok this is what he's planning to
do so what are you going to do
yes Jared only pay if - yeah
to each for is a move I mean it's it's
playable move but after f3 I'm not sure
if I have that much there
go ahead I paid this month your move 90
f6 mover now I'm happy that I have this
g7 square so my knight has some
potential okay so I'm happy to play this
move now he goes here 91
okay
okay night c1 now I go Bishop d7 just
trying to develop okay and this gives me
the connection you know I connect my
rocks so it goes f3
Brook fe8
developing my rock
now goes 9b3
now when he plays 9b3 what is he trying
to do with that night on v3 where is he
trying to go to yes yes he's trying to
play 95 ok he's trying to play 95 so
that needs to be prevented right we
don't want to learn allow the night to
jump in on c5 right so how are we gonna
prevent it absolutely absolutely b6 we
control the square we're not letting him
to come in and now at some point we are
preparing c5 as well
ok so again this is the last round game
of this year's US Championship begins
Grandmaster Ray Robson I'm black now he
played before to be honest with you I
was expecting something like a little
bit slower like Queen d2 maybe and then
e4 but then he played here afore
now he played Evo right away so what are
we doing here what are we doing
yeah yeah young students go ahead
well that's what he is trying to do what
I'm going to do though that's the
question what is the what is there and
negative thing with this palm push what
Square did he weaken okay what squared
did he weakened by playing the movie for
yes absolutely
he has weakened the f-4 square so that's
why you're gonna take advantage of it so
we go Knight f4 okay my goes on F 4 F F
4 F F 4 ok now I was Queen d2
attacking the night
now what's the idea
mm-hmm
okay so he's attacking the knight so
what are you gonna do now concrete he
wants to take your knight yeah he
brought the Queen over he's attacking
your knight tink little bit don't rush
tink little bit analyze analyze little
bit and then you can raise your hand in
chess you don't want to rush the key is
not to rush okay if you if you pace
yourself you make much better decisions
okay
yes
do you want to push the pawn in front of
your king hmm think when you push the
pawn in front of the king right that's
creating a serious weakness and that's
something you want to avoid to do okay
so you need to be careful doing that
okay
you
yes where we have audience our alive
audience on YouTube what kind of
suggestions they have which Knight to f6
Knight where the problem is with this
move if you play you're allowing me to
play Bishop c2 and then after g3 your
knight on the foot is gonna be
questioned okay so that could be a
little bit of a problem okay
and plus there is some discovery ideas
hitting the Queen so the bishop is
important piece in this position okay
bishops are important what's the value
of the bishops guys what's the real
value of the bishop yes yeah yeah but
what's the value yes three and a quarter
remember don't forget that quarter right
bishops are a little bit more valuable
so if you can get a bishop for a 993
pawns so that quarter could make a
difference so go for the quarter okay
top tuna let's capture the bishop okay
and we got the quarter now now
now what do we do
now what do we do here which piece we
want to bring into the game here huh
which piece feels like it's not in a
game right now to you yes absolutely
rook a to d8
okay d8 and now he plays here Queen III
now what do we do
yeah yeah if he had play the move Aoife
we had a screwed move Knight h5 okay so
he goes here and now I actually spent
some time here because I had few options
here so I was trying to figure out what
is the best move here for me
yes it kind of looks interesting but
it's gonna play like maybe g4 or
something
yes well I want to kind of strengthen
the position first so I played the movie
should be six to strengthen it up a
little bit okay now everything is
strengthened then I played a five
attacking my knight now the night is
under attack we placed ninety seven
ninety two
now we play c5 right we've been
preparing that break so if I see five
nine goes 93
now he's long-term plan is to play a
four a five so we need to do something
against that
now what to do he is stretching to play
some f4 f5 ideas
yes absolutely well I did see four first
he goes back here and instead of f5 I
played f6 first to break it okay because
now I want to take so if you place f4
and now because if I play a five right
away here sometimes chemical 92 94 it's
a great school for the night but if we
go here he plays a for now we can play
which move there you go perfect now we
lock everything up and we got some b5
ideas coming up so it goes here b5
before I have some nice Queen sight I
drown so this is actually very nice for
me and here I make a inaccurate move
rook f8 this was not a good move okay
because I should always leave the f8
square for my knight okay I should
always leave the f8 square for my night
guys okay
I should always do that so what do you
think I should have played here putting
the rook on a Fed was an inaccuracy
because I can no longer put my knight on
a fate
yeah actually yeah I should have just
read try to bring the even the night
night night be 896 with the beam cut
rook F 895
in ig5 he is putting pressure on the
bishop so he is putting some pressure on
the bishop so what are we going to do
here guys
yeah this was a problem that's why okay
faith was just in accuracy
he has been wait sorry Brooke what I'll
go back yeah yeah maybe but I played h6
here yes your question Ben Thomas image
here let's move
it's a move absolutely h6 here maybe it
wasn't the best a little bit wicked Mia
but ideally I want to get a night only
six guys but unfortunately I'm not
getting it here so he goes here nagas g4
trying to break trying to break the
position with g-force
trying to break the position with g4
now he's the problem is you know if I
take he has some f5 night of four ideas
so it's tricky
so I pickin h7 just talking my king to
the safety and I goes here oh by the way
I was thinking about this move you know
because it would be so beautiful to get
a knight on e4 here you know but the
problem is he takes and if I take with
the Queen he can take my knight if I
take with this he's got a little cheeky
and then he takes my knight so he gets
his queen out of the way
because if it takes the knight I can
take his queen so King aged seven and
now Queen f3
now he goes Queen f3 what do you do
what do we do here huh
ninety-eight trying to go to c6 he takes
I take that with a pawn because if I
take with the rookie as 93 now I was 93
the problem now here if I put the knight
on c6 I had to deal with this knife
coming in on f6 it was kind of
uncomfortable so I decided to put the
rukon g8 if he plays Knight h5 I go 97
okay so I'm just controlling f6 and I
goes here he is pressing me a little bit
here but I got a double up my rock so I
go 97 double up we both double up and
we're getting close to that time trouble
here position is still complicated here
okay it's hard to see who is better here
but he makes a wrong decision here he
plays the move b3
he is trying to get that his trying like
to take to take and play d5 or if I play
the move c3 wants to play Queen d3
what did I play here yes our YouTube
audience the problem with a forest they
will take on c4 take and d5 and then
have the spawns are gonna just come down
and crush me I don't want any pawn
advances on my position here okay I
don't want that so what else you can do
I don't want any part dances there yes
absolutely c3 that is such a strong
paths panel city that you want that past
pot so he came Queen d3 he was counting
on this month but there is a strong move
that he overlooked here who is gonna
find that strong move here that he
overlooked and now it's shifting it's
shifting towards my advantage
he thought he's just gonna win the part
but not so easy
what do we do
who is gonna find a move that is gonna
turn the tables here and give me the
advantage against him
when
got a few people suggesting Queen 86
[Music]
Queen f6 Queen takes f5 we're dropping
the Pesce we don't want to drop the
pitch count at five guys that's
important pawn right there it just takes
yes
yeah could double it will kind of
defending you know in fact I really want
to improve my night in this position and
actually I'm not too worried about him
taking on a five here I'm not too
worried about that
yes and I be it I'm sorry no closed or
closed Ophion nope
not quiet guys close but not quiet okay
much better idea you have that night has
a better destination okay that night has
a better destination here guys
that night has a better destination here
nope better correct yes correct because
we want to get a knight on his six guys
correct
now if he takes with a queen
we take I'm sorry I take I take you take
I take you take I take he take I go see
- okay my queen
so that's why you cannot take with a
queen and if it takes the night it's
very interesting I take check
I take check and I go check he goes here
and I go 96 look at that night now guys
wonderful on his six putting pressure on
f4 and d4 so now he tries something like
this if we take he takes back with the
Queen sure so we go here to poom and if
it does something else who can show me
the winning tactic we needed to step
away with the king on h8 so we have this
nice tactic now yes
four key take e.t key got it and we win
we get a queen okay
so
h4
King h8
Quincy to
so that didn't happen because it's
losing okay so it was Quinn b5 he tried
to get active and now we need a good set
up here we need to get that night to e6
we need to get that night to e6
how are we going to get that night to
eat six year huh
now we need to improve the Queen here
improve the Queen so we can vacate that
square for our night so I went here
Queen f7 getting that night only six so
he takes upon ninety six now I have
pressure on him I have pressure on f6 I
pressure on d4 especially I want to take
the pawn on f4 so now he takes here
Queen takes d5
Queen takes d5 now
now it's important here you can take the
palm so we have to get the d4 upon how
yes
better
hey Rach what else do you have
yes
people suggest correct attacking the
Queen now he goes here so that's where
he's keeping pinned now we go rock
before attacking the Queen and now he
goes here now I'm better here guys I'm
better even though despite being down
upon I'm better I have a strong past
pawn a four-pound is weak so we are
doing great here we are pressing ok now
we go rook g8 attacking the Queen Queen
c6 now we push him back now what can we
do here
still you have to watch out for some
tactics because he's got the rooks lined
up there on a G file
yes yeah attacking the rook now he goes
rook f2
26 trying to trade
take my goes here queen c5 attacking my
rook on d4 he doesn't want to trade
because if he trade my C pawn is very
strong so I can just promote the pawn so
it's very goes here he attacks my rook
what to do the rock is under attack
what do we do
yes clever you here our combination from
Brenda Knight takes h3 with yeah but
that the rookies hanging right now on
before that's the problem
let me do something about the rook yes
temples temples guys yes
d5 you mean
rook to d5 attack in the Queen now goes
here
now what's the tactic
word is the tactic
yeah that's now we go back to that
person's idea night XD three tactical if
he takes we have f4 check and we're
winning guys so night it goes night h5
now we need to take the rook take with
this if we take with the knight here's a
knight f6 check so we take with this now
goes check
now we have to go here in g6 he takes
the rook we take back and now he has to
take the knight back so we have a nice
advantage here okay we have a nice
advantage here guys but we still need to
be accurate okay so I gave him a check I
knew he's gonna go here so I repeat at
one time if he plays here I take take
and Queen d2 check and then I promote
the D pawn okay
so that's easy winning so that's why I
knew he is gonna go here King g3 if he
goes King to three then I repeated it
and now a strong move here needed
there are a couple of ways I could win
by what's their strong move here
now I played Group G for that way we
have some Quinn h1 ideas - okay
Quinn each one rotates to enough one
mate
for example so he goes back here and now
Queenie for trying to trade the pieces
if he takes I just take backward rook
the rook endgame is just winning
so he goes Queen b6 check and now what's
the safe square for the King to put in
the safe square we have King
King goes where so he doesn't have any
more checks yes absolutely and he lost
on time here and pursue position is
completely hopeless because I'm
threatening check if he goes here I have
made if he goes to g3 I go Queen to g4
mate so he cannot do anything got it
lukkage for King g3 and Queen's Hall
mates
any questions
perfect so yeah this was the important
last round win against Grand Master
Robson okay so it shows how to play a
position where it's blocked the key key
moment I think in a game it was pretty
close here where he played a move b3 he
shouldn't have not given me that strong
past panel see three position is still
complicated here but once he did this he
overlooked he thought he's just gonna
take my pawn he missed this Knight f8
idea that suddenly if he takes I checked
and I put my knight on his six and
they're not pressing okay so this is
what you really overlooked and now this
King h8 idea with Queen takes f5 okay
all right very good very good guys and
so this will conclude our first lecture
for today and we'll have a little break
now and then we're gonna have one more
lecture after this okay all right
[Music]
you
[Music]